AND GREG.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
HOURS FROM NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS SET TO TAKE HIS FIRST VICTORY
LAP SINCE THE CONCLUSION OF THE
MUELLER REPORT, CLEARING HIM OF
COLLUSION.
HE WILL RALLY SUPPORTERS IN
MICHIGAN WHERE WE EXPECT
MUELLER, ADAM SCHIFF, AND FISA
ABUSES WILL ALL TAKE CENTER
STAGE.
TRUMP SPIKING THE FOOTBALL ABOUT
MUELLER'S FINDINGS BEFORE
JUMPING ON AIR FORCE ONE.
>> President Trump: THIS WAS A
TERRIBLE THING THAT WAS PUT ONTO
OUR COUNTRY.
NOBODY HAS SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS PROBABLY NEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE.
BEAUTIFUL CONCLUSION.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE REPORTS.
AND THERE WAS NO COLLUSION AT
ALL.
THERE NEVER WAS.
EVERYBODY KNEW IT.
I WISH IT COULD'VE GONE IN ONE
WEEK INSTEAD OF TAKING ALMOST
TWO YEARS.
BUT THE RESULT WAS GREAT.
NO OBSTRUCTION, NO COLLUSION.
>> Jesse: LAST NIGHT, THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE'S GOING TO
RELEASE FISA DOCUMENTS TO HELP
FIGURE OUT HOW THE RUSSIA PROBE
STARTED.
TRUMP ALSO BLASTING ADAM SCHIFF,
SAYING HE NEEDS TO RESIGN FOR
ENDLESSLY PUSHING THE DEBUNKED
COLLUSION NARRATIVE FOR TWO
YEARS.
ALL OF THE REPUBLICANS ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
WHICH SCHIFF CHAIRS, ARE
DEMANDING HE STEPPED ASIDE.
IT LED TO THIS DRAMATIC
CONFRONTATION ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> YOUR WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE
TO PROMOTE WOULD DO MOSTLY FALLS
NARRATIVE IS ALARMING.
AS SUCH, WE HAVE NO FAITH IN
YOUR ABILITY TO DISCHARGE HER
DUTIES.
WE URGE YOUR IMMEDIATE
RESIGNATION.
>> MY COLLEAGUES MAY THINK IT'S
OKAY THAT THE RUSSIANS OFFERED
DIRT ON A DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
FOR PRESIDENT AS PART OF WHAT
WAS DESCRIBED AS THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT'S EFFORT TO HELP THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> YOU MIGHT THINK THAT'S OKAY.
I THINK IT'S IMMORAL.
I THINK IT'S UNETHICAL.
I THINK IT'S UNPATRIOTIC.
AND YES, I THINK IT'S CORRUPT.
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT, GREG, I
HEARD YOU HAVE THE DRINKS LINED
UP FOR THE 7:00 P.M. MICHIGAN
RALLY WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
YOU CAN'T WAIT.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
A VICTORY LAP.
IT'S GOING TO BE A VICTORY
MARATHON.
IT'S AMAZING.
HE DOES DESERVE IT.
IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS.
I FEEL BAD FOR THE AUDIENCE OF
CNN AND MSNBC.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING NOW?
THEY CERTAINLY ARE NOT WATCHING
THOSE NETWORKS.
THEY ARE THE OTHER VICTIMS,
THOSE AUDIENCES.
THEY WERE FED OR SOLD THE
JOURNALISTIC EQUIVALENT OF
SWAMPLAND.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE GETTING A
CONDO AND NOW THEY HAVE SWAMP
LAND.
IT SUPPOSED COLLUSION
DEPRESSION.
THE ONLY CURE IS TO TURN THE
CHANNEL AND WATCH FOX NEWS.
JOIN THE WINNERS.
YOU CAN'T FORGET HOW MUCH THIS
PHONY NARRATIVE COULD HAVE
DAMAGED THE COUNTRY.
IT WASN'T JUST A RUMOR.
IT WAS A PRETTY PROVOCATIVE
CHARGE THAT THE PRESIDENT IS A
RUSSIAN PLANT.
THAT COULD LEAD TO AN ACTUAL
WARLIKE CONFLICT.
NOT JUST FOR THE COUNTRY BUT FOR
MY PERSONAL LIFE, BEING MARRIED
TO A RUSSIAN.
THIS WAS MAKING MY LIFE HELL.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE ENOUGH
PROBLEMS.
>> Greg: I HAVE ENOUGH
ADAM SCHIFF, BEING THE HEAD OF
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
THAT'S LIKE MICHAEL MOORE BEING
THE HEAD OF WEIGHT WATCHERS.
>> Jesse: OUCH.
WHAMMY.
DANA, ADVICE FOR THE PRESIDENT
AS HE GOES OUT ON THIS VICTORY
TOUR?
THIS IS KIND OF A BIG DEAL IN
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
HAS THIS EVER HAPPENED BEFORE?
>> Dana: WELL, I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S EVER HAPPENED BEFORE BUT I
DO KNOW THAT THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE FOR A LONG TIME, IT
KIND OF NEVER HEARD ABOUT IT.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY PARTISAN
STRIKES.
EVEN GOING BACK INTO THE OBAMA
YEARS IT KIND OF GOT THAT WAY.
TO HAVE ALL NINE REPUBLICANS
SIGN A LETTER TOGETHER,
INCLUDING NUMBERS LIKE WILL
HURD, UNANIMOUSLY SAYING YOU
OUGHT TO STEP DOWN FROM YOUR
POSITION.
HE'S NOT GOING TO STEP DOWN.
THAT WAS A SHOW OF UNITY ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
I THINK IT'S POLITICALLY ASTUTE
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP TO GET OUT
OF WASHINGTON BECAUSE ONLY IN
WASHINGTON ARE PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT RUSSIA AND THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
OUT OF THE COUNTRY, THEY WANT TO
HEAR WHAT HE HAS TO SAY, WHAT IS
GOING TO DO.
AND HE'S GOING TO A PLACE WHERE,
WHEN IT COMES TO REELECTION,
HE'S UNDERWATER RIGHT NOW.
HE'S GOT SOME WORK TO DO TO TRY
TO SHORE THINGS UP IN MICHIGAN.
OF COURSE HE WANTS TO WIN IT
AGAIN.
BEFORE HE WAS TALKING ABOUT ALL
THE OTHER THINGS WHEN HE LEFT
THIS AFTERNOON, HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, THE JOBS
COMING BACK.
IF I WERE THOSE GUYS, I WOULD
TRY TO GET THE PRESIDENT OUT OF
WASHINGTON, D.C., AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE, NOT JUST TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
LAGO.
GO SEE AMERICA.
THE PRESIDENCY GOES BY REALLY
FAST.
AMERICA IS AWESOME, I THINK
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE HIM.
>> Greg: NATIONALIST.
>> Jedediah: [LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: WHERE WOULD YOU GO
IF YOU WERE THE PRESIDENT?
BESIDES MAR-A-LAGO OBVIOUSLY.
THOUGH THEY HAVE A GREAT
GOLF COURSE.
YOUTH YOU WOULD GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE BESIDES PALM BEACH, WHERE
WOULD YOU GO?
>> Jedediah: HIS MESSAGE GETS
EVERYWHERE BECAUSE HE'S A GUY
WHO TWEETS, HE'S THE GUY WHO
RESPONDS THAT WAY.
I WOULD FOCUS ON THIS FOR A
MINUTE.
I -- YOU'VE GOT TO DO YOUR
VICTORY LAP.
NO COLLUSION.
YOU HAVE TO STRESS THAT.
BUT I WOULD ALSO -- I WOULD GIVE
IT AWAY AT SOME POINT AND ALSO
TALK ABOUT JOBS AND TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE CRAVING.
THERE WERE SOME OF THE PEOPLE
WATCHING THIS GO DOWN THAT
INITIALLY WERE LIKE, LET'S LET
THE INVESTIGATION PLAY OUT AND
SEE WHAT THEY HAVE.
AT SOME POINT THEY WERE LIKE
THIS IS A WITCH HUNT.
IT'S GONE COMPLETELY OFF THE
RAILS.
HE'S GOT SOME TIME TO SAY I TOLD
YOU SO.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
I DON'T KNOW WHO WITH THIS POINT
IS LISTENING TO ADAM SCHIFF AND
SAYING THAT'S MY GUY.
THIS GUY IS OUTRAGEOUS OUT
REALLY WHAT HE DID.
CHAIR OF THE INTEL COMMITTEE ON
TELEVISION TRYING TO IMPLY FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME THAT HE HAD
ACCESS TO INFORMATION THAT
SUGGESTED NO, NO, IT'S
COLLUSION.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS GUY'S NOT
EMBARRASSED.
FORGET ABOUT RESIGNING.
HE SHOULD BE BOWING HIS HEAD IN
SHAME EVERYWHERE.
TRUMP, YES, YOU MAKE A VICTORY
LAP.
PEOPLE REALLY KNOW THERE'S VERY
FEW PEOPLE IN THE UNHINGED CAMP,
EVEN ON THE LEFT.
SAY WHAT YOU'VE GOT TO SAY AND
THEN PIVOT ONTO WHAT YOUR PLAN
IS GOING TO BE FOR 2020 AND
HARTIGAN TO MAKE THE COUNTRY
EVEN BETTER THAN IT IS RIGHT
NOW.
>> Jesse: JUAN, VERY CLEAR
WINNERS AND LOSERS AFTER THE
MOLAR REPORT.
SCHIFF IS A LOSER OBVIOUSLY.
HE SHOULD FOLD AND MOVE ON BUT
HE KEEPS DOUBLING DOWN AND
SAYING THAT HE HAS EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
EVEN THE MEMBERS OF HIS OWN
COMMITTEE ARE SAYING WE DID A
WHOLE INVESTIGATION ON THIS.
YOU'VE BEEN SAYING THERE'S
COLLUSION.
WE'VE SEEN IT.
THERE IS NONE.
>> Juan: I TELL YOU, STRONG
AND WRONG AND LONG.
THAT'S YOU.
I WAS LOOKING AT POLLS TODAY.
CBS POLL, 60% OF AMERICANS
SAYING THAT IT'S TOO EARLY TO
SAY IF THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
CLEARED.
CNN, HALF SAY MUELLER JUST
COULDN'T PROVE IT, IT DOESN'T
MEAN IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Jedediah: TOMAN, JUAN.
>> Juan: I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT
TO HEAR THE TRUTH BUT I DON'T
EVEN THINK THE PRESIDENT IS VERY
GOOD AT VICTORY LAPS EVEN IF HE
WANTS TO HAVE A VICTORY LAP.
THE BUSINESS ABOUT TAKING APART
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT HAS GOT
REPUBLICANS IN A TIZZY.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT JOBS AND
THE ECONOMY.
WE SAW COMMERCE NUMBERS OUT.
THEY PUSH THE NUMBERS DOWN IN
TERMS OF GDP FOR THE LAST
QUARTER.
3% GROWTH.
MR. PRESIDENT, DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
IT TO ME.
THEN OF COURSE HE HAS TO GO BACK
AND SAY WERE NOT GOING TO TAKE
AWAY MONEY FROM SPECIAL OLYMPICS
BECAUSE THAT WAS SO AWFUL AND
TOXIC.
YOU HAD REPUBLICANS, ROY BLUNT
OF MISSOURI, SAYING IT'S
DEPLORABLE.
OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS TRUMP ON A VICTORY LAP?
THIS IS TRUMP SEEKING FURTHER
INTO THE MOCK.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK HE IS
SINKING.
I THINK THE POLL NUMBERS AS YOU
LIKE TO CITE, WILL POP UP BIG
TIME.
>> Juan: THEY HAVEN'T POPPED
YET.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVEN'T EVEN
POLLED.
THERE HAVE BEEN SNAP HOLES AFTER
THE MUELLER REPORT CAME OUT?
>> Dana: I THINK IT'S TOO
SOON.
>> Juan: WE HAVEN'T SEEN THEM
MOLAR REPORT.
>> Jesse: I URGE YOU TO GIVE
IT SOME TIME AND YOU'LL SEE THE
NUMBERS.
>> Jedediah: IF THE MUELLER
REPORT COMES OUT AND SAYS
THERE'S NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION, WOULD THAT SATISFY
YOU?
>> Juan: I AM DYING FOR IT.
YESTERDAY ON HANNITY THE
PRESIDENT SAYING I'M GOING TO
PUT OUT --
IF THAT'S WHAT YOU THINK IS
APPROPRIATE, PUT IT OUT.
HOW ABOUT PARDONS?
TALKING ABOUT PARDONING PEOPLE.